hey friends and welcome back to rapid
fire language learning today we're
answering the question
how to improve your listening
comprehension understanding a language
understanding the spoken language can be
a daunting task and sometimes it can be
discouraging
after putting so many hours into your
language learning sometimes you just
don't understand what people are saying
this is normal and
here's my piece of advice if you want to
improve your listening comprehension you
have to abide by these two simple
principles
first listen to your target language
every single day for 30 minutes
and two make sure that you listen to
comprehensible
and interesting content and by
comprehensible i mean something you can
understand at least to
60 to 80 of your time if you do this for
months
on end i promise your listening
comprehension will skyrocket
if you want to know more about language
learning in general i have hundreds of
videos on my
channel thank you so much for watching
over and out